take your question thank you it seems
like three minutes into the game after
you died you typed uh gigi noob team and
all chat can you just run us through
what was going through your mind at that
time i shouldn't have died to that
frankly but like whatever it's fine
slayer slayer
you kept peeking and taking the mid duel
despite dying five times in a row and
all i can ask is why
i mean i might have died five times in a
row but like he was just lucky it was
whatever
a slayer slayer uh so how do you see
yourself improving you've been playing
this game for three years and you're
still in silver i'm not actually silver
like i know it says i'm silver but like
you know i think we all know that i'm
not actually silver um and i am
improving like i am i'm no longer
bottom fragging